non-minimalists
somebody asked me that they were like
well how much money did you have at one
point i'm like i never really had that
much money at one point like
like in cash i was like i mean i would
have maybe a couple million dollars in
the bank
but i only had like maybe 600 000 in
cash and they'd be like
and they look at me like yeah did you
not understand the question
you know i'm thinking yeah but you got
to live the rest of your life on that
money
or i got to get the money out of the
bank so my point is is that
is that um that all that
did for me was create anxiety
panic attacks unhappiness
um you know arrogance anger
i mean there were all these things and
at the time had no clue
didn't have a clue that that bothered me
doesn't everybody have panic attacks
every couple of weeks doesn't everybody
that
doesn't everybody can't you know doesn't
everybody not be able to sleep
you know don't you have to lay in bed
for two hours before you eventually pass
it don't you have to take a xanax to go
to sleep
that's crazy what do you mean you just
fall asleep like that what do you mean
that's crazy
so there's all these things that to me
was just regular life
yeah and so eventually when i did get
so i don't know what the the answer to
that is i mean
you know maybe maybe i live out the rest
of my life and it's amazing i don't
think so
yeah i i think i live out the rest of my
life maybe i don't get caught maybe i do
i think i'm so arrogant that eventually
i would have told somebody else and
they would have caught up with me yeah
listen there's hundreds of thousands of
law enforcement people looking for you
you're gonna get caught
right so um but i think what happened
was i got arrested i went to prison
i had two panic attacks when i was in
prison two
and they were literally as opposed to
the panic attacks on the street where i
literally stopped and if
there was nothing to sit down i would
have dropped on the ground in the indian
style and just sit there
i've done that before in a supermarket
because i was in the middle of the aisle
there was no place to sit i literally
sat down people are walking by like
what's with this guy wow
um because i just it was just
overwhelming and it only lasts a minute
or two
but it's not a good minute um and so in
prison i had two where i'm walking along
and literally i kind of like stopped and
i could feel the tingle
took a couple breaths and it was over
and i kept walking
and i'm i got 26 years that's the most
stress
that's what it caught up with so you
know
what happened was eventually
i start writing and when i start writing
my fellow inmates stories and i start
writing my story
you know and you start looking into
yourself and reading books about how to
write
um and how to write a memoir and and all
of the things that
i would have told you meant nothing
um you know suddenly you start you know
you start looking at yourself and
looking at your past and looking at what
those um
those catalysts are that cause you to do
certain things
and you know it starts unraveling and i
very quickly realize that you know that
you know you
you are a narcissist you you know you
are arrogant you are these things you
are
you know this isn't the media this isn't
[ __ ] this is what's happening and
this is just who you
are and it's horrible and it's it's a
bad situation and you need to start
working on it and although i
feel like i work on it all the time and
then i told you that i feel horrible for
like friends of mine
you know because i just dominate
conversations i have friends
that literally they'll say they'll be
talking for a couple of minutes and then
they'll say something like oh man that
reminds me my ex-wife
we're talking about me right now give me
five more minutes and we're going to
talk about you the rest of lunch
and you know and you would think if that
happened you would think that people
would get upset about that but
i i i'm always like i'm so glad you did
that
yeah yeah because i dominate
conversations
i will come in i will dominate the
conversation i will walk away 20 minutes
later and i don't know a [ __ ] thing
about you
and and that's just an [ __ ] you're
just an [ __ ]
well so here's here's the difference uh
i think and by the way here's
how matt cox is ryan nicodemus or is
josh milburn or is anyone else who's
listening to this i think
you just you began to discover some
things about yourself
and naming those things and
realizing that's not the person that you
wanted to be
ryan and i you know we grew up really
poor thought the the
key to happiness was to make a lot of
money in our 20s
and so we climbed the corporate ladder
and by
age 30 we were living the american dream
but
we weren't the people that we wanted to
be either we were
jerks we we had addiction problems we
um we had consumption problems
we had a lot of problems and we covered
it up because of the
the ostensible success and yours you
mean you were
you were very successful in in one way i
mean you were uh it certainly appeared
to be
exactly right and and i think that's
that's where we are and so
quite often we there's one
small compromise that's why i started
the podcast with this
small compromise of your values usually
it's because we don't even know what our
values are
at the time you're like i just need some
money and so okay i'm willing to make
this one small compromise
but then of course that one small
compromise leads to two to six to 20
to 1.3 million dollars in tampa or
whatever it is right and all of a sudden
you're like
how did i get here what was one bad
decision at a time
yeah and and when we're talking about
redemption i think the difference
of the matt cox of yesteryear versus the
matt cox of today it doesn't mean you
figured everything out right and i
certainly haven't figured everything out
but you have figured something out and
it's that the life you were living
before
was not a meaningful life right in fact
it was the opposite of that it was
causing immense stress
and and um discontent
and it may have been sexy you could make
a great movie out of it
right um but like you can't actually
make a good movie out of the real
contented
people the most contented people i know
like we're gonna have leo babalta on
here probably the most contented person
i've ever met
yeah his life the movie of his life
would suck
yeah because there's no drama you don't
want
drama in your real life it's great on
that glowing screen right
it's great in your book and it's great
that you've gotten past it and what i'm
seeing now
with matt cox and i i can see it i i i'm
looking
toward the horizon here and i'll just
say this i'll acknowledge you i'm
proud of you man like the direction that
you've you've moved in
like i can see this really developing
into
a meaningful life and so um it already
has i mean yeah
it already has yeah you know i mean it
just has i mean yeah
i i don't i don't know if you're
wrapping it up but i i
but i i mean i was saying like when i
was in
real quick when i was in prison i have a
friend named pete who's there for
um this is gonna sound horrible
he's there for conspiracy to to murder
to confidential informants
that we're murdered um oh wow didn't do
it
um just like everyone else yeah
actually wrote a book about him he's the
nicest guy you've ever met and super
knows who he is and i remember talking
to him one time and
we were talking and we're talking about
somebody else and and i was like why
does he act like that and he goes
i mean he just hadn't figured it out yet
and i go what do you mean he goes well i
mean
you can't come to prison and continue to
behave the way you did
prior to prison he is and then leave
prison and expect not to return
and he went he goes you have to come
here you have to figure
out who you are and what you're meant to
do and you have to do that
and leave prison he goes he'll be okay
and i went i said
i went have i figured i said well i need
to figure that he goes
i go i need to figure that out and he
goes no no you you figured it out
and i went doing what he goes writing
yeah
and so it was funny because after that
conversation people would say what do
you do when you get out and i was like
i'm gonna figure out how to make money
just being me